前回のあらすじ
はじめしゃちょーは、遊戯王全部突然売ると言い出して、
え～たくさんのカードの値段を調べ、チェックリストにカードを書くことによって、
11時間の時間がかかって心身共に疲れたが、その日のうちにカードを売りに行った。
しかし、カード量が多すぎて査定にすごい時間がかかったので、
その日の夜に、また、査定で何円もらえるのかっていうのを知ることになりましたので、
今は、しばらく休憩タイム!そして、この後編からは、その、査定でわかった金額がわかるようになる動画でございます。
皆さんお楽しみに!イェイ!
(決まった)
おぁ!
www
夜になりました!え～無事2軒のお店からは、終わりました、査定が終わりました、という
お話を頂いたので、もう一回、お店に行って、果たして、買い取りの金額はいくらだったのかを、今から見に行きます。
まずは、一店舗目!
まずはその、ノーマルカードとか、
ちょっとしたレアカードとか、安い方のお店から
まず行ってみたいと思います。
安い方でしょ?
全く想像つかないんだけど
まあ...
まあ...1万行いってればいいんじゃないかな...?
多分1万くらいかなと思ってるんですけど
この企画が始まって、もうすぐ、24時間が経とうとしております。
いかに高く売れるか！僕の持ってた宝の山は、何円だったのでしょうか。
着きました。1軒目のお店です。
では...行ってきます。
お、来た!
www
おーお!おーお!
これ何w
いや、すごいよ!
ちゃんと全部見てくれたみたいで、
金額がちゃんと、ばっちり、なっております。
そこそこ、
いろんなカードを買ってくれたようですね。
ブレイクスルースキルが900円で買われてる
金額の方を行きますか。
一店舗目の金額...
4万!...
40,765円でございます!
チェックリストに載らないカードを
うまいこと裁いたんだよ。
割とね、多分、仕分けがうまく行ってたから
この値段になったんだと思うんだよ。
ねぇもうこれで焼肉行けるもんね。絶対。
こっからが本番ですからね。
大本命はこの次のお店です。
チェックリスト入れて、
次が多分めちゃくちゃ高いと思われます。
2店目のお店に行きましょう!
まあ、正直、傷物とかもあるんで、10万...12(万)ぐらいじゃない?
そろそろ行くわ!
行ってきます!
気をつけて!
あのぉ...買い取り...してた...
(店員)はい、こちらになりますね。
(ピー音)
ぅぅぅぅわぁ
はい、大丈夫です
(店員)たぶん今までで(買い取り金額が)
最高だと思います。
あ、本当ですか!過去最高ですか！
ありがとうございます。
いつもありがとうございます。
また宜しくお願いします。
店員さんいわく、過去最高金額。
なるほど。
過去最高金額、過去最高枚数。
見ますか？
このタイミングで一口食ってw
なんかねえ....泣きそうなんだよね...
今まで...お金だけじゃ無いじゃん。
動いたりさあ、調べたりさあ...
それが全部含めてこの金額だっただと思ったらなんか...
遊戯王の映画4回見に行ったからね。
まあこれが...僕が...今までしてきた...
結晶です。
22万!
w
(22万)5535円!
wwwww
こんな感じですね。
952枚で、22万5千。
この姿面白いなwww
ヤベェよマジで...
これと、さっきの店舗のやつを合わせますと、
いやぁ、これ、予想の遥か上でしょ!
というわけで!
僕が...すべての遊戯王カードを売った結果...合計金額!
266,300円でございました!
スゲェ、大事なものを失った気がする。
でもあの量だとさ、1枚探すのにもさ、1、2時間で見つかるレベルじゃないじゃないですか。
って考えるとまあ、部屋を整理するって意味で、
有効に使うっていう意味では、間違ってなかったのでは無いかなと、思っております!
よし!
飯でも行くか!
飯行こうぜ、飯!
このお金で飯行こうぜおい!
もう食い放題だよ!
高級焼肉店行こうぜマジ!
はじめさん早く早く!
行こうぜ!うぉっしゃー行こうぜ行こうぜ!
うっ、風っ...
うわぁぁぁ!
ああああああああああああああああ...
俺は、
その日の夜中中、お金を追いかけた。
待ってくれ!
待ってくれぇ...
あっ!